you
[Music]
Thanks hi I'm Brooke I am a data
scientist at the ACLU and today I'm
going to be talking about the small role
that are in data analysis played in an
effort to reunify over 2,500 children
who were separated from their families
while trying to seek refuge in the
United States in that context we'll talk
about how to deal with extremely messy
and flawed data and how to create
efficient but safe ways to process and
analyze that data especially when it's
updated over time and especially when
those updates aren't consistent or
predictable but first we have to start
from the beginning with the broader
story of family separation so in
November of 2017 a Congolese woman and
her six year old daughter arrived at a
legal port of entry in California to
seek asylum they were today detained
together at first but after four days in
detention ice put the child on a plane
and flew her 2,000 miles away from her
mother to a facility in Chicago the
night before she was sent to Chicago as
her daughter was close enough for
Michelle to hear her screaming through
the night they only got to talk to each
other around six times for the four
months that they were separated in
February of 2018 ACLU lawyers met with
Michele and immediately they filed a
class-action lawsuit because already by
February it was clear that this was not
an isolated case
in March of 2018 Michele and her
daughter were reunited largely in
response to pressure from this
litigation but in that same month then
DHS Secretary John Kelly proposed on CNN
that family separation might be a useful
policy to help deter immigration from
Central America in May this policy
became official and was met with
immediate backlash both from the legal
community but also from activists from
regular people from families this was a
huge story that I'm sure you saw over
this summer and it really enraged
everyone as it should have in response
to that in June On June 20th Trump
finally administered an executive order
to stop the separation but this
executive order didn't have anything to
do with the more than 2,000 children who
were already
separated and so the judge in the
micelle case issued in an injunction and
ordered the government to reunite the
families and those efforts are still
continuing today most of the families
have either been reunified or their
wishes have been sort of gathered and
understood but this has been a really
really long and arduous process and it's
been clear the whole time that there was
not a data system in place to handle the
reunifications
data started pouring in around June
which also happened to be the time that
I started working at the ACLU and so I
immediately got involved with the case
to try to figure out how we can organize
the data that was coming in in September
the Department of Homeland Security
published an internal watchdog report
which stated that they struggled to
provide accurate complete and reliable
data on family separations in more
day-to-day terms what that meant was
that I would get emails like this from
our legal counsel with updates basically
what would happen is every week we would
get a joint status report in which the
government told us the number of
children that remained in various
categories and we would also get a data
dump of messy Excel spreadsheets that
Ella had been artisanally handcrafted
one by one and then never seemed to add
up to the numbers in the joint status
report and so my role as a data
scientist wasn't really to do any data
science it wasn't to make predictions or
run regressions or even to calculate
anything more than simple counts and
averages my role is to support the team
and what they needed to find out what
data was wrong what was missing and what
families might be falling through the
cracks and that boiled down to three
main actions organizing validating and
describing the data so that we could
find people ask new questions and
understand what was going on basically
that means rectangular hundreds of Excel
spreadsheets finding errors and
inconsistencies in those and then
calculating descriptive statistics so
that we could identify individual cases
that were coming to us and make sure
that the ad
it's media and legislators knew what was
going on
so for organization here's a snapshot of
the data that we've received so far and
data was still coming in as recently as
December this isn't big data by anyone's
definition I don't think but it's
certainly big enough to not be able to
do everything manually just looking at
one spreadsheet and it had some quirks
for example here are some different ways
that the unique identifier the alien
number which is kind of like a social
security number for people going through
this process here are all the different
fields that we could have joined on they
could call it an alien number a or we
can abbreviate child or we could call it
a child or a UAC we could call it a
relative or a parent or we could not
describe what those were and those could
vary across spreadsheets we could just
call it no and so my immediate reaction
in response to this data request was to
get everything in a nice single tidy
rectangle with all the information one
row per person but that clearly wasn't
possible one of the reasons it wasn't
possible was because some of the data
was simply wrong and we could have just
throw out the data that we knew to be
bad we had to follow up to the
government to say what is going on here
why is what is this error where is this
person currently in this case
particularly and I think in a lot of our
cases the data source is just as
important as the data itself and I think
that's the thing to keep in mind when
we're doing analyses but we still like
rectangles everybody loves rectangles so
the first step was to get everything
into a nice rectangle with list columns
and we did that with these packages I
really like the FS package because it
includes metadata about a given file and
then we could arrange those we could
sort by size or by the date that they
came in and then we could mutate over
various rows based on what the path
string was and
can map over all of those rows and read
the data in so here's an example of what
that might look like if we read in all
of the files that are that matched this
reg X pattern in a given folder we can
then arrange by the time that that file
was created and try to see you know what
are the updated pieces of information
telling us and once we have a handle on
that we can read all of the data in and
so we did this with a combination with a
bunch of Tidy verse packages per was
really really useful in unnecessary
escheat so what we're doing here just to
walk through is we're mapping over a
reed Excel function called excel sheets
so that we can see the names of all the
different tabs we're making it so that
there's one sheet per row and then we're
reading all the data and based on those
sheet names and so once we have
everything at least in one one location
in R we can start to ask questions and
see if the data makes sense and spoiler
alert it often did not here are some
examples of some errors to put it
lightly that we found in the data there
were a lot of booking dates that were
later than people had been deported or
children who had been reunified before
they had even been booked in we had 22
children who were reunified with
themselves and then 73 parents who had
deportation dates after that essentially
was not allowed anymore and so some of
these obviously are data errors but we
don't know anything more about what is
this location of that actual individual
and there's nothing we can do from a
data perspective once we get to this
point we have to turn around and say
what is going on with these 22 rows
because it's really important whether
they were actually reunified with their
parent but the identification number was
entered wrong
or if there's still somewhere else we
don't know and so that we did this with
a series of assertions and filters to
help us find errors and so we have that
nice rectangle of list columns we can
unnecessary of information we have tons
and tons of columns because of the
variable name problems that you saw
earlier but this way we can filter to
which are the rows in which the child's
alien number was the same as the adults
alien number and then we can look at
what that path is and say this is the
excel sheet where we have a problem this
is the source of that information and
return to that source and figure out
what's going on we can also use
verifications and assertions which we
can put right into a tidy versatile type
so that we are making sure that for
example all of the children only have
one age and one gender associated with
them so if we're going to tabulate how
many children under 10 are separated
from their parents
we're not double counting any one and so
once we get at least a subset of the
data that we feel reasonably trustworthy
about we can start to describe it and we
can start to put it in pictures so again
if we take that pipe from before and we
pipe it into a ggplot we can look just
at a distribution of the ages and
genders of all the children and this
patterns jump out that we might not have
expected the two big patterns in this
data for me are the jump between
five-year-olds and four-year-olds and
the time trend of especially teen boys
so one of the sort of peculiarities of
this case was that children who were
zero to four were put in a special
category and expedited for reunification
but and so the way that was reported on
there were around a hundred children who
were between the ages of 0 & 4 and
around 2500 who were older than 5 which
makes it seem like okay this is bad but
maybe we're doing a better job with the
the
just children when you cut the data
differently we find out that more than a
thousand children were under the age of
ten when they were separated from their
families another important thing that we
wanted to visualize and we did this with
leaflet is where the children were in
space so I think we think of family
separation as a border problem and it's
true that most people did come in
through the southern border but that's
not where they stayed children were sent
to essentially foster care facilities
all across the country there were ended
up being over 400 children that ended up
in New York and a common question that
we would get from legislators and from
state representatives where who were the
people in my state are there any
children here where are they what can I
do for them what can I do about them are
there any parents who are here how can
you know how can I in Nevada or Nebraska
or South Carolina how can I be most
useful and some of those questions we
weren't able to answer because the data
was so poor so one of the things that we
didn't get accurate and consistent
updates on was reunification date we
really wanted to know how long children
had been separated but we weren't able
to effectively and responsibly calculate
that because there was so much
missingness and there was missing this
because when you don't have data about
something or someone you don't have to
hold yourself accountable and no agency
was ready for this when it happened
because the office of refugee
resettlement hadn't had to deal with the
problem of reunifying children before
and this is because the data that we
collect reflects what we value and when
we aren't collecting data
something or someone isn't being counted
I think this was said most succinctly
and clearly by the federal judge in this
case who commented that we have methods
of may of keeping track of the
belongings and the objects of people who
are coming in through this process but
we had no system in place
to provide effective communication with
with children and to keep track of them
and to eventually reunify them with
their families and it became very clear
that no one had really thought this out
in a appropriate way before this policy
was enacted and this question of not
collecting data and not counting people
is really at the root of a lot of the
issues that were worried about and
fighting for right now in the Civil
Liberties space a lot of the cases that
were fighting are really cases about who
gets counted so recently the ACLU won a
case that barred an edition of a
citizenship question to the short form
census which advocates were worried
would reduce census responses in a lot
of these populations that are already
marginalized and already have good
reason to be suspicious of government
data collection but when we figure out
who gets counted we can start to make
choices based on that so another case is
whether or not we record people's LGBT
status in something like the census when
we don't collect that information we
don't know how we are able to make
choices based on that population and
when we don't collect information
maintain a data structure for children
who are separated from their families
we're making decisions about what is
important which is in data are just as
important as what we have and that
doesn't mean collected on everything
there are a lot of reasons why a full
surveillance state isn't appropriate but
it's important to reflect on what we're
collecting and how that reflects what we
value so I can't finish this talk
without thanking all of the ACLU lawyers
all of the lawyers that other private
sector firms and other nonprofits in
both America in both North America and
in Central America and all of the people
who wouldn't stand for this the people
who the literally hundreds of thousands
of people who came out who marched in
the streets who donated who called their
representatives this was a really really
motivating issue for a lot of people and
while it was devastating there were a
lot of hopeful aspects because even
though every each of these individuals
and these pictures has a lot going on in
their lives they knew that this wasn't
something they were gonna stand for and
I imagine that group of people turned
activists include a lot of people in
this room so thank you are there any
questions
[Music]
we'll have time actually for just one
question
is there somebody who would like to ask
a question here we go
that was awesome first but how easy was
it to obtain data from agencies did you
have to use like FOIA or some other
procedure was it pretty much just yeah
though yeah the reason we got that data
is because we were in a case and so we
got a car discovery and I will will
caveat that with the data that we got is
only as good as what we got from the
government and so there are other
organizations that and and including us
that have found other cases that weren't
originally included in that class I step
around 2,600 members and so that's a
really good point to pull out thank you
you
[Music]